new threat stalker new threat loosens
loosens I feel safe I feel like this is
a progression that I want to take do you
like my halo no what
what's up Bob Bob Bob do you like my
halo I don't see a halo right there I
don't see anything no I don't see it
what it's just for you there's seafoam
grenades ooh nice what do you what do
you do wait why do you think you have a
halo I changed my appearance and I put
on a halo under my accessories Oh weird
here let me see let me see if it works
for me yeah I see that yeah Bob you go
hey so it does work what did you do it
wrong way did you save my next energy
just exit oh this is cool Bob it changes
colors your reward box I think oh you're
right you're yeah yeah did you get the
rule bucks you use you're [ __ ] with
me right
I mean Bob's got it these do you see it
on the mirror and you're on house mines
I don't see why a mirror I see my oh
yeah oh yeah that's cool it just change
cool wait maybe take it off and on again
did you do that already yeah you guys
are [ __ ] I know you're [ __ ] with
me you have to be [ __ ] with me okay
it's just a cosmetic what do you care
halo no why is my whole chat saying you
guys are lying to me because that's what
they would say yeah obviously if the
depth of this game don't even let us
play fair that oh we might be the - oh
wait no the devs are [ __ ] on screw
with us yeah okay yeah and when I say
little bub thanks man
yeah that's cool it's cool it's too bad
you can't have one Wayne you know weed
yeah yeah are you ready to destroy
another level to win definitely minor
power here I can get another minor power
start the mission with a bandage and
something like that my need I didn't
even eat my energy bar what's the energy
bar do with left click for a short
period of infinite Sprint's that's
actually probably pretty I could use
that to escape alright well we'll go to
a holy Easter now okay guys so we need
to be really good friends so though so
that the shape doesn't sense our
betrayal I believe in each other in all
of us especially you Wade
yeah this time in this and leave me
let's all work together in the spirit of
being really good friends wait I have to
tell you could see your halo the whole
time and I'm really sorry about it
alright alright I accept mark anything
you wanna say I love myself more than
anything
I accept that mark hi except it to me to
accept accept it
oh I see it wait your halos there thank
you not joking it's there I feel like I
knew this
don't fret the Chester here what chest I
don't see a chest well then I guess it's
just for my internet huh you I cut out
yeah is it my internet cutting out did
you guys not hear me talking no no no I
knew your thing I think the devs are
kicking me from the server for being an
a-hole no no no no but Bob you can't be
in a hole you have a halo which means
you're an angel so I did not connect is
me a god damn it what's up can you
invite me again possibly yeah well I
think you have to be kicked out first
you just got cookie oh geez I don't like
the controls game connecting to haast oh
I just heard kachunk
alright I'm here I think maybe good work
mark thank you I did it again god I turn
around and I try to grab it and I fall
immediately Bob I'm sorry that was a
very teamwork he liked of me didn't go
down it's okay doesn't reach far enough
down for me to jump it doesn't it's a
way above my head that doesn't make any
sense
look look how short it is I can't I'm
gonna walk around Oh
oh my god tiny do you see how sorry are
we
way to throw mine from it I could you
know what wait you're a good friend you
know that I'm pretty and I try my best
hmm I'm pretty good friend did you just
grab okay you grappled the roof I
thought you grappled the Fed no get
around no it's fine
wait what they just groans outline a
sign what the hell what what happened
what is this person here I mean there's
oh my god who's that oh my god what's a
[ __ ] developer what the [ __ ] is that I'm
gonna I'd love to do anybody called the
stalker I might be in Gawker yes what
was called why are you playing with us
then you can't some man who's competent
I can't help it everyone wants a piece
you cannot grapple the drone oh that
would have been sick though it would
have been say your grapples over there
on the fourth market looking at you mark
you should probably get out of this fine
it's fine everything's fine
[Applause]
wait stop don't don't
are you yelling at the person yeah but
they can't hear me cuz I didn't press
the push the top button okay what
happens if I take down someone and then
just leave them but they don't trigger
the enemies that's got to be a dev right
what the [ __ ] was that what was that I
don't know I did I just get
tranquilizers
what I swear to God I just got
tranquilizer dart 'add I lost all my
stamina stalkers or other players who
try to kill you is that a fact
can you do that I want to do that that
sounds fun I don't even know that was an
option that sounds right up your alley
someone shooting me someone shooting
arrows at me and now Jim I don't like it
a stalker recorded you catch them before
they escaped Oh what what do you see
that video
yeah no what game was already so hard if
you beat the level with the stalker you
can then play as a stalker oh my god
okay yes the stalker and how are they
such a kids across the street or there
in that building or near it well he was
shooting arrows at me from in the
backyard
wait there's a tree house over there see
over there no I've gotten two pieces of
evidence are you just like recording
them yeah there's there's some broken
stuff that it wants you to look at oh
wait here out it's out here oh I see
okay we're good okay okay it's down no I
think I think it's down below so what
happens if the stalker gets away with
your video of you guys or whatever every
time good I thought that was someone
else
soccer soccer soccer where right there
right there on the fence can i tase them
or something we can do something with
them yeah you CNM wait no I think they
ran around the front yeah I think they
did we should just get on the ground and
go from there I guess getting spewpa
licious music none of us have like a
weapon to take this thing down with and
the stalker person right god damn it
oh boy what do you want lighting some
fall damage Oh crushed market too just
too late I've got one of those too late
too late too late man how you doing Bob
i boned that was bad that was a bad
sequence I just alerted a sleeper the
shape is coming for me
well I'm just gonna go try to see if I
can get to the objective what is that
thing that's not the speed trap that's
something else some kind of noisemaker
I'm imagining if we walk through it
it'll make noise oh wow
by Wade I mean good luck to you I would
thank you for making the noble sacrifice
away from me I'm not saying it's a I
found the speed trap oh man wait I wish
I could be there for you but I can't I
think I've gotten oh hey it's the stuck
or not gotten the soccer was right
behind me I just see the stalker right
here I'm not sure what the point is
you've got you [ __ ] kidding me you've
got to be [ __ ] kidding me I'm just
spending my time trying to get the hell
away from the shaper
now the shapes on me or at least it just
was no it says close your eyes with Z to
see the shape it's still it's still is
still off the targeting thing I just
heard a teleport but I can't see it
oh oh that's not good oh that's not good
I long as you guys are still doing the
objective I'm okay do it today I'm not
if I'm I mean lead kind of oh wait can
the shape here when I talk yeah I got a
cellphone
nice nice nice oh that's it we just
gotta get out wait get the hell out of
here the shapes down here yeah yeah I
see it is it coming up it's going shape
is coming from me now alright bottom up
here by I'm leaving I'm in an area I
have no idea where it is you're so far
mark and you find an exit up top and
then just navigate up top dude I I have
no idea I don't know this area so I'm
guessing the stalker got away or got out
I saw the stalker down below and then it
disappeared I really don't know Bob be
careful there's another person in the
backyard yeah I am a little lost we have
to make our way toward you anyway mark
so no I mean I'm downstairs in an area
I've never seen right I legitimately
don't know where this is just look for
like stone stone tunnels at the edges
and those usually lead to like house
exits or whatever yeah I think I've oh
well the shapes here apparently
you stole from us I'll god damn it just
go guys
we can't you had the item oh you're
right I did I'm trying to navigate over
towards you mark to where you know
you'll never guess where I was cuz I
have no idea
[ __ ] stalker god damn you stalker
it's a soccer bite you it just sent me
another picture of myself running away
from I think the shape which what does
that do
I don't know it's not like anyone can
read it I am NOT super close to water
but not super far thank you for the bid
sergeant me it apparently catch grab
stalker it'll boot the stalker out of
the session game ok that easy
I guess it's our fault for not having
any like weapon things probably mmm I am
making my way downtown mark thank you oh
god damn it there's something isn't
right on my ass again oh wow what the
hell brick Jesus where did that come
from I don't know oh you just got run
through the sound things so you go
quickly through those you go slowly
through the speed traps is this where
you Marc yeah we're yeah I go far and
left who the [ __ ] are you oh god damn it
lucid oh this [ __ ] sucks yeah and
you're leading them right to Bob hey Bob
you got company I'm shape ok good I
think there must be an exit down here
somewhere there's like this blue tunnel
like right behind where I am right now
Oh Bob do I hear a shapee maybe
alright make sure you didn't run away
okay you grab the thing it's right down
there on the ground I'm gonna go try to
get managed I've got I've got one
actually I'm health actually
surprisingly apparently we can
flashbangs of the shape I'm gonna try to
get you Wade and then Bob just be ready
to go for the exit whoa whoa whoa whoa
Jesus Christmas yeah all right yeah I'm
fine do I have flashbangs okay coming
for you Wade almost there
shape is on you mark careful I'm okay
for now
Oh God Oh why do you have to be on a
sound thing oh no all right I've got one
flashbang we're gonna go towards Bob
okay sounds good I do not have a new
exit so there's no there was a blue
tunnel there I swear us yeah yeah it's
right where I'm at
okay we're coming up where you were mark
oh my god boom let's go okay dream I
don't know what the foam does I'm
entering the twist apparently the twist
it's it's called the twist the twist is
you all die all right we're gonna we're
right behind you all right he's still
there wait wait if you have a candy bar
eat a candy bar we don't have a candy
bar and I've got I can heal though all
right
no it's next oh yes I have a grappling
hook
we might need a grapple to get down I
don't know okay let me hear oh wait we
can go over here this this if you come
this way this drops down onto this flat
platform okay it looks like is this
gonna be oh there's a stalker down there
here's how think wait here or something
oh you're in the light Bob oh yeah just
go for it just go for it I'm just going
let's just go out where we're going oh
thank you wait what's in the box what's
in the box
all right listen we stick together and
get out where the hell are ya further
further this way further this way dead
end all right there's a door here yeah
where are we where are we I don't know
what I don't know where is oh my god
where are we going what is this
is that sound 1 or a speed trap speed
trip
where are where are we where are we this
is a nightmare where you do not belong
no kidding we're trying oh yeah
thanks stay big big help there yeah I
see yes the shape the shape oh this [ __ ]
okay oh where the whole freak oh it's
here it's here
alright wait like right here what the
help get grant okay
this way there's a ladder oh well the
shape has me thank you who where oh my
god I can't see the laughs there's a
ladder in here this is where that ladder
is oh nevermind ladder ladder do it well
I'm getting shape alright goddamnit oh
god I'm being shaped right now wait run
away no I had the cell phone yeah wait
where are we oh you're at the top I I
tasered the shape and got shaped I'm
confused I'm making my way back to you
guys
oh [ __ ] the cellphone is right at the
bottom of the stairs
Oh bold bold move bull move bull move I
like it I like it bold moves all right
I'm gonna prank call that a-hole
thank you I'm gonna get the cellphone
and start climbing you go for daddy
you're just gonna so it was not good I
agree all right let's do this
dude that dude is like right beneath us
yeah he's been down there all the time
it's fine if you have energy bars and as
your ended you're by yourself and let's
get the hell hacking Frick out of here
no energy bar but it's which I did all
right well maybe I won't do that then I
mean you have the cell phone so if you
if you can make it I'm Ivan tazer still
so I can Oh what the [ __ ] it it's it's
on me way over here exits way over here
oh [ __ ] Niccolo boys oh god oh god no no
no no no shape shape shape no no no
shape come with me boys [ __ ] no it's
right there I know it's okay it's okay
we got this where is this is it straight
ahead or is it all done here it's done
here yeah
oh God he's on close guys let's go we're
right here
[Music]
screens with that [ __ ] stares in the
face oh there we go
oh my god we did it hey was that XP we
got three experience points three I got
five twenty three yeah me too but it
looked like three because my bar didn't
move at all mmm dude [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
is so stressful oh I definitely want to
remember oh yeah well I don't get it
lower this game I was told is very more
heavy mm-hmm well we did it so suck on
that game
yeah wait I already have that stalker
dossier a stalker dossier can be used to
invade another game and work against
other players if you never invade anyone
you will be opting out of the mode and
games you host will not be invaded in
the future so wait did you opt in no
maybe that was just our introduction to
the stalker thing because I said in the
future like you get invaded once okay I
just told me after the last mission I
leveled up to five or six or whatever
and it told me that a stalker was
unlocked I did not bend anything sure
sure sure wage
yeah I wouldn't lie usually if you're
watching this in the future on my
channel go subscribe to Bob and Wade
guys that are watching the streams go
watch Bob place and call of duty because
I think I'm gonna wrap up too
yeah that sounds good facebook.com slash
mu ys k erm or as he's known on the
streets little skirm my ass he is muy
skirm that very very skirt I'm very
squirming
[Music]